in the locker room if somebody looks at
me I make [ __ ] straight heterosexual
eye contact with them I don't [ __ ]
around look at Mike if they look at my
[ __ ] I look back I go that's what
happened baby
that's what God gave me I got that
[ __ ] pat-pat-pat [ __ ] I got that PAP
[ __ ] dude I don't you know I'm not
covering my [ __ ] enough in the locker
room I'm not covering my [ __ ] in a
locker room dude that's looking Eminem
lyric cover mechanic in the locker room
who covers the tank in the locker room
I'm not the kind of guy who covers his
characters black you gotta seem a little
penis I mean it's the B nerdiness go
home do not mix me yeah but a guy okay
black dude he rubs everything for real
none of that rhymes do not mix me yeah
but again oh god okay and his lack of
room and everyone's like whoa how does
he find everything that rhymes he
doesn't dude you never find a penis to
mean it's Dean Dean it's a penis only
nabina the name is marina Williams you
think your penis being a Serena Williams
Serena Williams doesn't run with penis
you know forth
but an orange Trump you're like all
right I guess who's on my phone's gun or
annoyance Trump but I'm thinking what a
man is gonna come from a character lack
of um penis do you see my penis between
wings and dude and [ __ ] 45 year old
white dudes are like that's [ __ ] so
good how 45 years old is it too like
Eminem and and think he's the best
rapper I'm not talking on Eminem dude
the guy is one of the best rappers of
all time it's just so funny to think of
a 45 year old guy name like Derek that's
just like oh man Eminem is the greatest
rapper right like that you know what
that is that's so la Kenyatta dad to
think mm is it so it's so dad from
Pasadena to be like Eminem is is he's
great because he's a lyricist like it's
some of his stuff is poetry some of his
stuff is poetry you know a guy a white
guy who's 45 that has beige hair and
wears Dockers has said that a million
guys like that have said that literally
a million I don't I'm not really into
his when he's talking about penis and
Serena Williams but you know that [ __ ]
in the locker room lyric